it is actually a great a great pleasure
to be here in the cultural heart of
London and I would like to thank my
lovely hosts Maria who's also already
been thanked but also Amanda berry
Jeremy Brock lucy guard and cassandra in
real okay I might do that a few times
but yeah truly truly happy to be here
and and and I'll tell you why it's not
just because BAFTA is an important
cultural institution which is needed now
more than ever in this climate of
rapacious commercialism it's not just
because bath 2 stands for truth and
integrity and innovation in the arts
values which are not invincible or
Almighty but are in fact quite fragile
and must always be nourished and renewed
and I'm happy to be here not just
because I've received two Baptists and
the encouragement that they confer has
pushed me to continue to try my hand at
serious work and I'm happy to be here
not just because we're gonna have a
probing talk tonight which is going to
make us incrementally better people or
at least that's the hope the truth is of
if I'm completely honest with you
which I'm going to try to be completely
honest tonight I'm happy to be here
because I'd be happy to be just about
anywhere that wasn't the United States
of America right now and particularly
Los Angeles I'm not sure that there's
any community more shameful today than
Hollywood now the sex crime capital of
the world possibly only beaten by
Bangkok or the US Senate Congress in the
White House maybe we would include Nigel
Faraj in the media in that Bunch
I don't know but I lose either way
because before I was a screenwriter I
was a journalist so I do seem to have a
flair for joining publicly disliked
communities and let me just say although
manure goes without saying that the the
sexual criminality that has come to
light among Hollywood's most powerful
men stains all of us but I know for a
fact
and I know from my own experiences
working on three motion pictures with a
female director that sexual oppression
while it may be prevalent is not
inherent in the arts or the demands of
creative work it seems odd to have to
say this but I'll say it is entirely
possible to be creatively unshackled and
free to scoff at convention to dismantle
taboos on screening on screening excuse
me while maintaining absolute respect in
real life for the boundaries of other
people and I would argue that it's
actually easier to make humanistic art
if you practice straightforward humanism
and your dealings with real people
having said that what I'd like to focus
on today is something that I think is a
bit lost in the current conversation
about the criminal behavior of powerful
people although I hope you won't think
it's too cynical if I point out that
Harvey Weinstein's exposure is a
sociopath coincided with his loss of
economic power in the indie film space
in any event I'd like to turn to the
actual work that's being produced in
California right now in the mainstream
kind of area of the movie business and I
do feel somewhat qualified to comment on
this even though all my movies have been
independent films I have a fairly good
idea of what they're up to at the
studios since many of my friends work
there and I had been known to go to a
studio party from thymes I'm okay so
there are two articles of faith and
forgive me if you already know this but
some of you in your sort of cultural
isolation United Kingdom may not know
this there are two articles of faith
that are hold sway these days in Los
Angeles the first article of faith is
that within the American movie business
the room for serious popular art is
basically gone the movie business has
shifted nearly all of its energy to the
tent poles of the youth market I think
you know the films I mean I won't
mention them well talking about the
superhero pictures that are all quite
similar to each other that feel as if
they've been engineered rather than
written they are essentially high
surface value commercials and I mean
that in the technical literal sense of a
commercial that these are motion
pictures used to sell action figures
video games theme park tickets and so on
and the truth is the ancillary value of
all of those other products collectively
outweigh the the economic value of the
movies themselves having said that I
don't think there's anything
particularly wrong with this trend which
we've been living with for some time
right now any more than I think it's
wrong to read fairy tales to children
these are stories for kids which is just
fine with me and and and actually some
of them do contain quite skillful
storytelling and fine acting logan comes
to mind as an example of that and more
importantly nearly all of those movies
have a global impact and the truth is
that nobody in fallujah I saw Detroit
but I imagine some people there did see
Captain America and in the big picture
of the tentpoles a very big picture do
you push out a value set a basic value
set of let's say the importance of fair
play equal opportunity justice winning
over evil and these values are in fact
pillars of Western culture and just as
an aside I know the for the folks who
work in the sort of counterterrorism
business consider these films to be very
important transmitters of democratic
ideals believe it or not they do so I
don't think theme park movies are some
degrading or pernicious influence except
insofar as they suck up energy and money
that was once devoted to making movies
for adults what you might call real
movies okay that's the first trend the
other trend that's going on in Hollywood
right now the second article of faith is
that we ought not to be too terribly
discouraged by the industry shift
towards making movies for kids because
the adult material has simply migrated
to television as I'm sure you've heard
TV is where the action is for a writer
these days and the line is that on TV
creative risks are rewarded on TV
complex complex subject matter is
encouraged morally ambiguous characters
are welcomed and so on I think the
notion that TV is a savior might be
slightly exaggerated for a number of
reasons which I won't get into and
although the gap is closing between
between movies and film
there are creative possibilities let's
say they're latent in the form of
television that I think have yet to be
explored and I don't hold myself above
television anyway in fact I'm writing a
television series right now about the
u.s. presidential election the most
recent one
the working title that was going to be
what the [ __ ] just happened
but I I mentioned that at a dinner to a
Clinton camp person was that and she
stole my title for her book so now my
working title is the end of the Republic
but in any event I am NOT ready to give
up on movies because I happen to believe
I do do this that that neither the tent
poles nor the abundance of highly
addictive television quite replicate the
impact that real movies have had on our
culture and that they can continue to
have however the question has been
raised and I've discussed this with many
friends in the business and I would say
this is the part from the Harvey
conversation this is the dominant
question today in LA given that there's
a very high bar now set for theatrical
success and given that audiences are
mostly made up of younger people looking
to escape their parents and given that
good things can now be attempted on
television the question is what's the
point of making a real movie anymore so
I'm going to take the rest of my time to
lay out a very provisional answer to
that question which I sketched out on
the flight over here it's quite a simple
theory really first of all let's think
about the movie-going experience for a
second and compare it to television when
we go into that dark room we give up
certain rights that we have that have
become second nature to us namely the
right to have exactly what we want when
we want it that's the great advantage of
TV in this era of on-demand everything
television lets us stay in our bubbles
and remain in the basically consumers
position of choosing what impressions we
allow ourselves to absorb in the movie
theater on the other hand you can't
switch the channel adjust the volume or
unless you're a complete [ __ ] check
your Instagram feed you can't even
really use the bathroom because the the
entire seating arrangement of the
theater has sort of been designed
and to make that difficult to get up and
squeeze past everybody else in the aisle
so in a very real sense you're trapped
when you sit down to a movie and I think
this is actually the the most salient
feature of a motion picture of these
days it's often said that the
distinctive feature of films over
television is the size of the screen and
you hear directors talk about that quite
a bit but I don't think this is quite so
true anymore with the prices of large
television sets falling and it is quite
possible to replicate a cinematic
experience in your house except for one
thing you're in your home and you're not
trapped you're free to pause you're free
to grab a sandwich check the internet
and if you're really at wit's end you
could even read a book so given that the
movie theater audience is by definition
sort of a captive audience voluntarily
but captive it's natural for a writer to
ask what to do with this power what to
do with these people who at least for a
short period of time are captive because
I guess if the kind of writing I'm going
to do is the sort that elicits constant
engagement and is constantly pleasurable
that sort of writing might well be
suited to television might well be
suited to competing against other
channels but if on the other hand the
writing is meant to be challenging and
by that I mean challenge audiences
specifically let's say in the case of
Detroit by asking the audience to
undergo a bracing experience or by
challenging audiences by asking them to
reshuffle their mythologies of race
class or gender as let's say Barry
Jenkins say with moonlight or challenge
an audience by asking them to expand
their notions of the limits of grief and
guilt as in Manchester by the sea or
challenge an audience by deconstructing
the experience of time itself as Nolan
did in Dunkirk that I think one is
better off attempting these sorts of
artistic maneuvers with the captive
audience of a theater now for me as a
former journalist the type of challenge
I like to pose are drawn from that
background the sense of responsibility
that journalists have to engage in the
hard truth
of the world working with Katherine I
sought to take that impulse and combine
it with let's say imaginative filmmaking
that's something that I had to defend
somewhat after we made zero dark thirty
about the hunt for Osama bin Laden
because a lot of important people in the
media and politics maybe thought they
were more familiar with a story than
actually were insisted that journalism
and entertainment can't mix without
destroying the quality of journalism but
we were convinced and I remain convinced
that the combination does more to
command people's attention and capture
their imaginations than either
traditional reporting or purely
fictional storytelling does on their own
and I think the result doesn't have to
be necessarily any less truthful than
what's in a newspaper and in some ways
can be a more truthful now the case of
Detroit in this instance I believe that
Katherine threw down an extremely
serious and hardcore challenge to the
audience's probably more so than is
generally appreciated actually Detroit
is a movie about a terrible crime it
follows the killing of three young
african-american men by three white
police officers in 1967 there's obvious
parallels with the present but the
decision to write about this particular
story came after a meeting I had with a
man who had been one of the survivors
named Cleveland Larry read Cleveland was
Larry as he's called new movie was it
was somewhat hard to find and he hadn't
talked about the events in the film for
nearly 50 years but the long and short
of it if you haven't seen the movie is
that in the summer of 67 he was a
up-and-coming musician the singer of a
band called the dramatics a singer in
the band called the dramatics and one
summer night at a place called the
Algiers motel he had an encounter with
law enforcement that left him
permanently wounded mentally and
artistically and here's the important
part
what brought Larry down what caused this
sort of loss for him it wasn't a flaw in
his character
it wasn't a bad decision that he made in
the heat of the moment it was merely
shitty luck for being in the wrong place
at the wrong time and more generally
racism this somewhat defied conventional
narrative technique because in the usual
screenwriters tool block toolbox
character determines fate to a large
degree and in this case I had to write a
story in which the character had very
little agency at all in the face of a
unjust society kind of pressing down on
him excuse me and having him in when I
started the troy'd I thought of it as
Larry's story one man who has his voice
stolen from him but it didn't turn out
to be that simple without shortchanging
the larger events swirling around him
and the cast of characters gradually
grew and as I wrote I found myself
working in a sort of horror genre vain
except in this case the supernatural
element was replaced with the all too
real terror of racism and the narrative
as it emerged had elements of a crime
saga set against the backdrop of a city
on fire and again in another twist on
convention the perpetrators in this
story turned out to be the police having
said all that ultimately and I am
actually getting to a point near
ultimately what we wanted to do with
Detroit is to bring the audience in
tight proximity to the commission of
these crimes the crimes committed by
police against these these basically
innocent young people so that rather
than being in the unusually comfortable
the usual comfortable spot of sitting
back and assembling clues and evaluating
motives like with most crime stories the
idea was to put you the audience smack
in the middle of the thing forcing you
to absorb what happened to the victims
it's another way of saying that is that
Katherine wanted the audience to undergo
the same sort of humiliation and loss of
dignity as the victims did I think about
that for a second that's an incredibly
daring thing to do and a very big
challenge to the audience I believe the
Katherine took this approach because she
thought it was the only way to be
truthful to the stories that Larry and
the others told and the only way to
connect their experience tarz
and create a genuine sense of empathy
which you could argue is the
the purpose of art in the first place
now the question of course is that it
does Detroit work in this regard I think
that's quite a complicated question
actually
so hanok totally a friend of mine who's
an architect saw the movie and said he
felt as if he was being punished for
something that he hadn't done I've heard
this from a few other people he implied
that there was something in that
experience that was unfair to him again
that experience of reliving a crime in a
very visceral and detailed way and that
I think he implied it that there was
something unfair in the way we made him
feel complicit and the crimes that were
being committed as he was forced to
witness them now his wife who works for
an international NGO perhaps a better
person had a much different reaction she
was moved by the film deeply actually
and she told me it made her reconsider
her life's priorities and she was now
thinking about shifting her career
towards fighting to end racial injustice
so here you have a married couple
presumably they share a common worldview
split on the question of the movie my
guess is they had an easier time after
they saw Thor but but the reaction that
my architect friend had as did sort of
stay with me because when you watch
Detroit the feeling of being treated as
if you are complicit is quite powerful I
don't know that I've ever felt that
about a movie myself and Mithila ng of
unfairness is also quite powerful but
the more I thought about it the more
sense it made to me because this is
actually the kind of feeling that
follows naturally from the way the
Catherine directed the movie the other
people that were treated unfairly or
Larry and the people in the motel as
well as their families who had to go and
identify the bodies the next day they
could not for the life of them
understand why this has happened to the
people that they loved and the reason
they couldn't understand why their sons
were murdered is because there was no
really good reason
it was simply unfair now this is where
things get a bit complex
some people like my architect who by and
large were on board with the agenda of
the film not agenda that's not quite
right but the themes of the film have
suggested to me that it's a pity that
the movie probably won't be seen by
people who needed it the most need to
see the film the most I think he meant
by that this sort of I can't get through
a whole lecture without saying Trump the
sort of stereotypical Trump supporter
let's say from the depressed American
heartland who perhaps harbors racist
sentiments and the idea is that this
movie was really aimed to those folks
but they're probably not likely to see
it I'm not so sure that's right
Detroit is not simply a story of racism
of a bad cop who is terrified of black
people and meets out justice according
to skin color what it's really about if
you look at the film closely is the
complicity of the white people around
this pathological cop in excusing and
justifying his crimes it's really about
the way that racism works in an
institution like the Detroit Police
Department circa 1967 and what it says
is that racism allows pathology to
flourish uncorrect it in other words
that racism creates a sort of
environment in which truly horrendous
acts go unchecked in other words the
film kind of connects ordinary
complicity with the worst kind of murder
and in that regard I would say that
maybe the greatest challenge the film
presents is not to about racists it's to
the people who actually applauded
themselves for having advanced views on
race relations if I can be blunt
white people liberals who consider
themselves the friends and supporters of
African Americans but who aren't
actually doing anything to change the
lingering and justices that we all
acknowledge exist to people like my
friend who absolutely do not consider
themselves complicit in a racially
unjust world the film suggests that
perhaps he is wrong it does this through
its emotional impact through the way it
challenged him to absorb an experience
he would think he had absolutely nothing
to do with
his first intellectual response to me
which is wait I'm not complicit of not
responsible this is on a fair sort of
fades when you consider his emotional
response because if you're not complicit
why does the movie make you feel so
strongly anyways you can imagine that
was rather hard to figure out how to put
all that on a poster so in closing I
don't want to leave you with the
impression that making serious movies is
some kind of righteous cross that I bear
I do it because I want to mostly and
because I really couldn't think of
anything else to do and while it can
seem like a struggle and a fight at
times it's also a great privilege that I
don't take for granted in some countries
you risk being thrown in prison for
trying to dismantle prevailing thought
structures in my country and in this one
we don't face that threat or only
serious fight is against let's say
Mickey Mouse and door and I think that's
a pretty fair fight in the end so far it
seems to me that Thor is winning Captain
America is winning but as I look around
and continue to see daring work being
produced and as I think about the
commitment of organizations like BAFTA
and all of you here I think in the long
run I like our odds and I think we're
going to be fine thank you
[Applause]
it's what wherever great well thank you
very much indeed
um thought-provoking as we would expect
I want to put unpick some of the things
that you've talked about it a little bit
there but and we've got a few clips to
show from some of the films and I'll
also invite you to take part as well but
let's just go back way way back we if we
may I mean you said just now you're
making films because you couldn't think
of anything else to do
I mean don't buy that for a moment but
be really true I think I would be a
pretty decent dog trainer I don't really
have any other skills but you were a
journalist so what kind of a journalist
were you print long-form investigative
reporting narrative nonfiction magazines
particular areas of interest were I did
would I do I did political reporting I
did I covered youth culture drug culture
that was I was a good beat what else
true crime I was early on the sort of
surveillance aspects of the internet the
environmental movement the labor
movement lots of different never did
celebrity journalism wasn't never quite
cool enough for that but they would but
I did this sort of long articles that
people don't read anymore
but and it was a series of articles that
the death and dishonor series of
articles for Playboy that that gave you
your first kind of connection with the
film industry and that was Paul Haggis
and in the valley of the place I can
never cut print is it ella ella well you
could say either what all Paul says
either but yeah Paul bought that article
I wrote a piece for Playboy that was the
a true story of the soldier who was
murdered by his platoon mates when he
got back from the war in Iraq and this
story was about his father trying to
figure out what had happened to his son
his father had been an MP in any way
Paul option that article and I went out
to Hollywood to work with him on the
story and answer his questions as he was
sort of developing a story and that's
how it all got started for me
and what was it that you saw during that
process I mean what what were the
possibilities that then we could see in
the form well first of all he had a
really big house and I thought Jesus
Christ I'll never get one of these as a
journalist no I mean III it was just he
was very very very very generous with
his time and he really showed me how a
certain way of breaking down a story I
mean just in a technical sense and I
mean I course I'd studied writing in in
the as far as prose quite a bit but not
but not dramas and so it was it was just
sort of seeing behind the curtain of how
he of how you put a story together that
made me feel that next time I had a
story that I liked I would try to do it
myself and that and that next one was a
story about the bomb squad which became
a little longer yeah yeah and so I mean
the hooker was so striking when we all
first saw it because of because of that
sense of unease that is there right from
the beginning even then we don't really
know we're not actually invested in any
kind of traditional way in the character
that was clearly something I was that
something that you and Kathryn Bigelow
developed together that always that
something that you knew from the very
beginning with the story that you wanted
to try and do which parts are well the
idea that you feel right from the
beginning you feel really uneasy I mean
this it's about it's about stress and
trauma oh yeah well that really came out
of that sense of unease came out of my
experiences when I was in Baghdad I went
there as a reporter and I was hanging
out with the bomb squad and and I
absolutely terrified for the entire time
I was there and it's it's it
that one of the one of the features of
that war that was a bit unusual is that
the enemy was not clearly identified
they weren't wearing uniforms and there
was no clear front so anytime you left
the base it was potentially a dangerous
situation and I wanted to capture that
that sort of constant level of anxiety
which I guess a war historian would say
that might not be unique but I think it
is actually fairly unique because even
in Vietnam you know which was obviously
quite bloody but there were there there
there was a very clearly defined front
and there were there were periods when
if you were a soldier you were in combat
and out of combat course even in the
base you could get attacked but but in
Iraq there is really this the sort of
360-degree threat and so that was one of
the impressions that that I had that
that's stuck with me and so there were a
lot of conversations with Katharine
about how to put that on the page and
into a movie and that so that that idea
that anybody you come across even in the
sort of hearts and minds kind of
conversation with somebody on the street
there's always that level of level of
threat so I mean did you you'd observed
obviously having worked with Paul Haggis
I mean the whole kind of screenwriting
business did you go away and study lots
and also films cuz it was so a short
that film in terms of the screen height
thank you no I mean I bought all the
books but I they weren't they weren't
that helpful because they were all first
of all some of them were very
complicated and I couldn't understand
what they were trying to say and second
of all it seemed to me that it would be
easy to retroactively Lee put a scheme
on a work of art and say this is how the
art was produced but that's not really I
mean if it was really that simple
everybody would be you know cranking out
important works all the time so I mean
III guess I learned by by doing it and
by studying movies that
that I liked and by having you know the
good fortune of having known Paul having
having that Catherine John Logan who's a
playwright and prominent screenwriter
was a friend at the time who gave me a
lot of his time and I was just lucky to
have people kind of walk me through the
basics and then doubly lucky to have a
director in Katherine who's willing to
try some of the more sort of
unconventional screenwriting ideas that
I had I was that something that when you
say try I mean that was to what extent
do you have lots of discussions before
you ever got to shooting about what
might or might not work well in the case
of her locker I mean I wrote but I don't
know how many drafts but a lot of drafts
and it took quite a while to figure out
how to how to do what I was trying to do
but at least I had from the beginning us
a sort of clear objective and so if I
guess I'm talking about like technique
more than intention
well let's can we see the first clip
please from her okay
you're the guy in a bomb suit no sir sir
that's sergeant James he's right here
hey James yep someone's here to see you
oh you're the guy in the flaming car
sergeant James afternoon sir uh yes sir
well that's just hot [ __ ] you're a wild
man
you know that uh yes he's a wild man you
know that
yeah I'll shake your hand thank you sir
yeah how many bombs have you disarmed
I'm not quite sure sergeant yes ask your
question 873 873 800 is 73 that's just
hot [ __ ] 800 is 73 they're counting
today sir yeah that's gotta be a record
yeah what's the best way
to go about it's arming one of these
things the way you and I sir that's a
good one I spoke like a wild man that's
good it's a great scene because it's
it's sure it's very economical at the
same time there is so there are so many
levels of the kind of results-driven
leadership that you see and the complete
isolation on the other side I mean I
suppose that's one of the that's one of
the great aims of screenwriting is it
should be able to get something like
that over in the scene as short as that
economy yeah that's quite important I
think although I do think most
screenwriters are good at that I mean
the funny thing about that scene is that
it's actually as a scene it's a little
bit it's it's quite conventional in the
way it's shaped but but the other thing
that I guess it's not not as may be
widely talked about with screenwriting
is is sort of imagistic nature of it and
because anything you're writing is
basically gonna be photographed so I
mean I like that scene it's fine but I
don't it's not one of my favorites just
because the things I'm more proud of
have to do with laying out the imagery
in the writing that tells the story
because finally I mean it should have
said that in the lecture but that's one
of the things that differentiates movies
from television is the the power of the
imagery did you always have that sense
when you you know when you were print
journalist as well was that the way you
wrote it I think when I was a print
journalist I was copying movies as far
as the the like the imagistic style
which I mean most people do these days
it's hard to write any kind of prose
without it sort of being influenced by
the power of the camera and I think
writing as a whole is God more imagistic
not true maybe that might be good that
would make
I mean with generations born in there I
mean I'm comparing to like the 1700s or
something but even from you know second
half of the 20th century always I think
that probably does have to be the case
but in terms of but economy is not
something that you can be imagistic but
not necessarily help the economy and I
think it's that knowing when to stop to
make it more powerful is the means that
something that you find how can you
judge that well mostly I write for
actors so what specific actress no well
yes specific actors who were in the
movie but but just in general I'm pretty
aware that someone's gonna be performing
the lines and so I try to write in a way
that gives as much gives them as much
space as possible to to have as
complicated a performance as so there's
certain kinds of writing that's very
directive and that's very expositional
where the actor doesn't really have much
room because they're there basically to
convey information and it'll sound weird
if you convey the information with like
too much color so I try to avoid that
kind of writing and do writing that's
does the smallest amount of exposition
possible and gives the actor the most
room to kind of explore you know subtext
and
different sort of layers of meaning and
the economy has something to do with
that but more and more so just having a
certain amount of space in the line I
know if that makes any sense but and
many rewrites onset in the case of her
locker yeah there were there was yeah
it's a great privilege to be able to
watch something and then see that you
know where it works and where it doesn't
work and to be able to fix it on the fly
some actors don't like that Jeremy
really didn't mind so that was great
so obviously look at tremendous success
all those Oscars BAFTAs
did that to have that much success with
your first big screenplay did that you
know sometimes that can be paralyzing I
did it ruined me yeah so I mean did you
feel how either there was then a few
years before you came up with 0.30 but
had you been working on that non-stop
no after after the her locker I tried to
do a studio movie which turned out to be
a really bad idea I mean the idea for
the movie I think was good and it still
may yet be made but years and years of
work that didn't really pan out so and
then when that didn't materialize I
started working on a story about the
hunt for bin Laden and it was about the
failed hunt for Osama bin Laden in 2000
and 2001 in Afghanistan right after the
invasion and it was about a Special
Forces team a army Delta unit that had
gone into the hills of Tora Bora and
then come very close to finding Osama
bin Laden but failed and as I was
working on that and writing that we were
actually casting that and pretty well on
her way to making that movie Osama bin
Laden was actually killed in real life
and so that making a movie about the
failure to kill him at that point seemed
kind of perverse
so that was the second script I wrote
that didn't go anywhere so then I
rewrote that whole thing more or less
from scratch at Pat and that became
Jared or 30 this is just a little bit
like you live by the sword die by the
sword when you get involved in topical
material but that seems to that always
seems to you the waste girl well they
won't hire me for anything else as the
problem yeah I do
but they but you know and I've I know
I've tried to get those jobs actually
but and I say honestly I'll do a great
job with this like science fiction thing
you're gonna you're gonna love it and
they're like that's fabulous well let's
take a look at the clip now from 0.30
please
I really need to talk to you about
beefing up her surveillance operation on
the caller we don't have a surveillance
operation on the caller someone just
tried to blow up Times Square you're
talking about some facilitators from the
detainees seven years ago said might
have been working with al-qaeda he's the
key to bin Laden I don't [ __ ] care
about bin Laden I care about the next
attack you're gonna start working on the
American al-qaeda cells or kept the
whole bin Laden is the one who keeps
telling them to attack the homeland if
it wasn't for him al-qaeda would still
be focused on overseas targets if you
really want to protect the homeland you
need to get bin Laden this guy never met
been on this guy's a freelancer working
off the [ __ ] Internet no one's even
talked to bin Laden in four years he's
out of the game he may well even be dead
he might as well be [ __ ] dead but you
know what you're doing you're chasing a
ghost full of [ __ ] network girls all
around you you just want me to nail some
low-level mullah pack of Dulles you can
check that box on your resume that says
while you were in Pakistan you got a
real terrorist but the truth is you
don't understand Pakistan and you don't
know al-qaeda either give me the team I
need to follow this lead or that other
thing you're gonna have on your resume
is being the first station chief to be
called before congressional committee
for some burning fat burns to capture or
kill bin Laden
you're [ __ ] out of your mind I need
four texts on the safe house and ralindi
floortex on the safe house in Peshawar
either send them out or send me back to
DC and explain to the director why you
did it no sorry
are you gonna say no I just Jessica's
pretty good in that scene insane but the
thing that I always remember is when
Kyle walks away is just totally trivial
thing but when Kyle walks away that door
that he closed supposed to slam and it
would like sometimes he went slamming
sometimes it wouldn't and on the one
good take it just sort of like that
because that's what happens life doesn't
necessarily follow those those kind of
beats and things so you made brief
lessons in your when you're talking just
now about people making comments about
Jared r30 who didn't really quite
understand what was going on one of the
things that did keep recurring as the
kind of argument was if you like the
point of view of the narrative was it
too close to the CIA point of view was
it I wonder what you feel about them
because to engage film has to have a
point of view well I mean it follows the
CIA so it does certainly follow their
point of view or not that it's a
collective where they all think the same
but it was very the film very much
follows the point of view of the people
who were intimately engaged in the hunt
for bin low let's put it that way and
that was actually a quite a small group
of people and that scene is a fictional
scene I don't but but it does represent
a true phenomenon which is that this
this group of people who toiled away
on the bin Laden lead were first certain
period of time for a number of years not
taken very seriously within the agency
and the agency did in fact shift its
focus I mean I think President Bush is
more or less on record about this a did
shift its focus away from finding bin
Laden particular so it kind of gets to
the heart of what I do I mean the scene
itself is not it is not strictly
speaking factual but it does actually
represent and embody probably hundreds
of conversations that were had about how
many resources to put on the mob and as
the other thing no it doesn't bother me
I mean that the charge that the film was
somehow representative of the point of
view of the CIA officers I mean that was
sort of the point of doing it in my mind
yeah so I mean the only the only
sticking thing is there the only
sticking point there is that because all
these people were undercover or at the
time they were in their cover and most
of them were still active duty when the
movie came out you know I wasn't able to
trot them out on stage or put them in
front of a TV camera and had to sort of
back up the thrust of the narrative and
so there were quite a lot of people
talking about the movie who weren't
undercover weren't privy to you know so
anyway was interesting was an
interesting situation but there was also
I suppose that the the argument about
whether the depiction of torture or
whether that was there was any kind of
suggestion that it was not that you were
being an apologist for torture but that
he was suggesting that all that rather
the narrative was suggesting that you
know tortured worked basically provided
results yeah that was an interesting one
because I mean it was obviously a part
of the movie but I think the extent of
which he became heard of a political
conversation around the film was I think
to put it bluntly the movie is a lot
more sophisticated than the conversation
around the movie became and I think the
movie is aided by the ambiguity of its
depiction but but there wasn't that that
ambiguity
room for the ambiguity didn't exist in
sort of the politics of the US and so we
got a little bit drafted into some
agendas that people had at the time and
continue to have and I mean I'm
supportive of those agendas so it was
sort of a mixed bag for me but but the
fact of the matter is that that it's not
a news flash but that that torture did
happen and those scenes are a lot more
authentic perhaps than people realize
and it would have been really strange I
think to omit that from the story as
some people might have wanted or to
portray it as a sideshow because it
wasn't a sideshow wasn't the black sites
and the gulags and all that stuff that
the CIA did was actually quite central
to their efforts for a period of time so
I think as a culture we should face that
and not not shy away from it at least
that was the point in the depiction to
me and the fact that there would be
debate around it and some of it that's
not particularly well informed and and
by the way one other thing that the film
depicts people involved in in the
torture program as then going on to
other jobs in the CIA which at the time
I mean I knew was actually a fact but
hadn't really been discussed and
recently it's come out that that isn't
that I mean there are people and senior
leadership positions now some of this is
in the news that that you know had a
pretty direct hand and all that so I
think the movie was actually pretty
clear cited in that way but it's sort of
about more than that I mean ultimately
it's about the price that we paid as a
culture for for chasing the bottom and
and when there is discussion around the
film that that's that's good you're
welcome all of that I mean I guess your
background would prepare you for that
well I mean nobody likes being
criticized but you're good but I thought
look we were on the front page of the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
and The Washington Post on the same day
and I think there was more calm
sation about torture as a result of this
movie then there had been at the time
that the torture was that even at the
time the torture was first exposed by
whoever exposed him in Washington Post
back in the day so I was quite pleased
by that and you know you make these
things and you can't you can't police
what people how people respond to them
or what you know what the what the
culture does with them and it's it's
satisfying if there is a conversation
that kind of comes with the territory
and and so to me it suggests that the
work had an impact which I don't know
where you could really ask for so how
then did you decide to move on to the
summer of 1967 and Detroit I mean how
many did you know well there are a lot
of other projects in between that you
were navigating between them yeah there
were a few few false starts in there
that that came the I was probably
looking at about 10 or 15 other things
at the time and I had read the John
Hersey write a book about the the
Algiers hotel it today which is an
interesting but not his best but
interesting and in in this sort of
texture of it and I read the book on the
recommendation of the president of my
production company who I I didn't know
the story to gave it to me and then it
was as I say one of probably 10 ideas
that we were kicking around and I went
up to Detroit to meet with one of the
survivors who's who as I said in the
speech Larry read and because after
reading the book I thought well is there
anybody around that can still talk about
this and so we hired some researchers
and they came back and said here's this
guy's phone number and I called him and
he didn't to talk to me and eventually I
did did persuade him to talk to me and I
met him in his apartment up in Detroit
and it was really that meeting and that
conversation that I I was so moved by
his story that I felt
it's by new walking out of there that I
was gonna write about him so I mean in
retrospect it's it's it's easy to talk
about these sort of like social
motivations but the truth is I was just
moved by his story and what he had gone
through and his sort of commitment to
continuing to live as an artist
despite this trauma that he had
undergone and I don't know it's just
that I'm often inspired by real people
and in the Sirdar 30 was actually much
the same way I was casting around
thinking it would be great to now rescue
this year and a half of work I'd done on
the hunt for bin Laden with a new story
about that line but I didn't have a
story until somebody told me somebody
told me that there was a particular
analyst who had been involved in the in
the hunt and that and that she was a she
and that she was quite young and so
forth and so I thought oh that's
interesting and then it was it was sort
of inspired by the reality of that I'll
put it that way
so with Detroit there's there's an
individual whose story you know watched
her but I'm against then the whole point
of Detroit is it isn't really his story
in that sense
so you can't I mean you can't have that
idea kind of sprung fully-formed or
maybe it did I don't know the idea of of
creating this kind of very intense
environment where as you just talked
about you know that that sense of how it
is going to make us question but when
how did you how did he get to that well
it was always history in my mind even
though it's probably writing about other
people how do I get to work how did you
get to the the fact that the actual if
you like the technique the idea of
having that that kind of crucible of the
incident itself at the center of it no
really that just seemed like the way to
go I don't know that there was any big
complicated thought
involved some of its just instinctive
and I try not to bore myself I mean I
think if I'm getting bored while I'm
writing then that's a problem and I
should do something else so and part of
it was just wanting to really recreate
what it might be like to undergo that
experience you know we have all this
imagery from iPhone videos of these
brutality in the US and they're kind of
quite moving but there's something a
little bit removed about them and
distance about them because you're not
really in the moment you're just sort of
catching a snippet of it and so I
thought it might be interesting to
recreate what one of those moments might
actually feel like from the inside and
also just cinematically I know that that
Katherine and I over the years have
talked a lot about dramas that unfolded
very contained spaces something that
interests her so it was really a
combination of those two things we've
got two clips to show one of which is
quite short which is actually from the
police talking to young Melvin smokes
the the young security guard and well
let's play the clip and then I'm going
to ask you questions first tape please
Alice hmm no sometimes when a black guy
is put in a position of authority other
black guys they like to sing what you
out okay because I'm not supposed to
tell them what to do when we have these
conversations we do them in stages okay
Stage one witnesses stage two suspects
what state you mean you don't know what
stage where no could you specify for me
yeah when stage two you're a suspect so
just a little bit but that that scene I
actually do quite like
but it's it's that question of getting
into that 1967 I mean so complicated in
terms of the attitudes the way that the
power thing plays out you know all of
that how do you find so much steeping
yourself in all of that must go on
before you get to that stage before
writing that you mean yeah it's a lot of
looking at news footage interviews at
the time police reports documentaries I
mean the event itself was fairly well
documented because there was a there was
a investigation by the Detroit Police
and then there was a Department of
Justice / FBI investigation and then
there were a number of reporters that
looked at it and then John Hersey
famously wrote a book about it I mean he
was also a reporter so there was quite a
lot of material to go through him and I
probably had 10 or 15 boxes full of
transcripts and stuff in my office and
so yeah I just immersed myself in the
material for probably about six months
and then but honestly that scene as
influenced as much by that as by
playwrights and so forth and just the
sort of what I like about it is how it
kind of moves and there's a sort of nice
fluidity to it but yeah a bit of
homework for sure
well the second is from the actual
incident inside the the Alex at the
motel where this perhaps a quick word
about this character cross the the the
young cop who is going to who is who is
not that's not the name of the real
person there isn't real person this is
actually based on a real person yeah
that whole scene just the one you just
saw his pace I mean that velvet his muse
that's a real guy he's still around and
I spoke to him quite a lot before
writing the script ending that so the
way I work that that he was charged even
though he was basically innocent he was
charged with I think it was assault and
he was interrogated and so forth so that
that's very much drawn from real life
and then as you say the other character
which I guess we're gonna see yeah well
Paul type of cultural played so bravely
yeah will by the way is the nicest guy
you'll ever ever meet and I mean
extraordinary talent but also based on a
also based on a real-life individual
whose name has been changed for any
number of reasons but but somebody who I
think represented a kind of and the
character certainly embodies as I was
saying in the speech not just racism
that's that's a little too easy but also
but also like a real murderous you know
sociopathic character trait and and it
was a allowed to exist in the police
department in those days I mean he was
eventually forced out but not not until
not until after he had killed four
people we could see the clip please
let's not be stupid in this situation we
still have a crime scene here and you're
all suspects each and every one of you
don't look at me turn around face the
wall what's call on doing the shooting
huh somebody better start getting
honestly me hi I want that gun we looked
around we didn't find a gun doesn't mean
it's not here don't find it yeah and
congratulations it is an extremely brave
performance and yeah quite a lot of
actors I think probably being quite
nervous of taking that on anyway
magnificent job there but fee that whole
thing about find that gun and there is
no gun I mean that that is actually a
kind of broader political thing that is
a if you like that almost a systemic
thing quite often within various forms
of authority within when they can't
actually find the source of the problem
and the hunt gets more and more sort of
panicking and more hysterical within
that yeah for sure and the other feature
that I mean it's just if you you know go
a little bit past that clip is that the
the crime and I did to me this is one of
the more interesting things and it's
depicted quite clearly but the crime
which is these police officers killing
these kids didn't really occur in some
dark alley somewhere the State Police
was around the National Guard was around
and so another a number of people were
aware of what was going on maybe not in
the room when somebody was being killed
but they were aware of this sort of
intensely hostile situation and I don't
know that's just extraordinary to me
that's just extraordinary
what what kind of mentality would have
had to
I've been operating for people to have
been aware that this was happening and
not stopped it
it's a good question I think because it
cuz I mean it you could ask yourself
that about things that are going on
today
what kind of mentality might be
operating that would allow these sorts
of things to happen because I mean
police works very hard and I have
friends who were police officers and so
forth and I I'm not anti police in any
way really not and and III have a lot of
respect for anybody who puts on a
uniform to serve anybody who goes into
public service of any kind I but clearly
at that time in Detroit there was a
mentality that existed in a Police
Department which allowed this kind of
thing to occur and maybe that mentality
doesn't exist in Detroit anymore I would
argue it probably doesn't the Detroit
Police Department has changed a lot it's
not actually one of the more diverse
departments in America and small towns
send some of their cops up to Detroit to
experience big-city policing but there
are still a lot of places more than
where the departments don't reflect the
the the people they are meant to be
protecting and serving but the idea that
people don't don't report abuse of
whatever kind it is or atrocities or
whatever it kind it is when that
certainly hasn't gone away as we know
from yeah all sorts of current events
one way and another I'm gonna open this
up now to questions from you as well of
the hand up here and on the front when
they're a couple of microphones so you
could well if you can get this tip to
here please and this couple yep up at
the back there Thanks
thanks very much it's been very
interesting to hear us speak tonight but
one thing I wanted to ask you is about
your process so it sounds like you do a
lot of research in your projects but
when it comes to actually writing that
first draft and it's the start of your
working day and you've got a blank page
what's your process for getting that
first draft I don't know I think I mean
basically I procrastinate until it seems
you know it seems very irresponsible and
then at that point I sit down and write
and but I do like I do for me it is
important to try to do the research and
not not not Freddie high-minded reason I
just don't want to be completely full of
[ __ ] when I'm sitting down writing a
character who you know I don't like
techniques or an experience that I
haven't had myself and so even though
there's fictionalization the idea for me
is that that absorbing the actual
history or the actual facts will you
know make me a better a better writer um
I sort of got a process question as well
you mentioned that your journey began
when Paul Haggis optioned your article
and that you then got to look behind the
curtain and such with working with him I
just wondering if you could talk again a
bit more about process and in particular
how you sort of I mean I think you're
absolutely brilliant at sort of
balancing character with action and sort
of finding this sort of each in the
other and I just like to ask you about
that well thanks I I don't know that I
have they it's just instinctual really
and I people have asked me about the
structure of this of Detroit because
it's a bit odd the way the movies put
together if you think about it it's in
fact it's maybe kind of stupid I mean it
opens up on a bunch of people who are
not actually in the movie for example
and then it spends a great deal of time
diagramming a situation that is that
just merely the context for the actual
drama in terms of the first 15 minutes
sort of diagramming the riots and
rebellions and so forth I don't know
that there's a rational explanation for
that I mean I could come up with one
after the fact I'm sure but but but
mainly it's just instinctual about
what's gonna keep the audience or what's
gonna keep me interested and I think
that's how I work and I you sort of
assume that if I'm interested maybe
somebody else would be too
and I actually find that quite
liberating because it's much easier not
easier but it's it allows me not to have
to be confined to the rules if you will
of screenwriting most of which are just
moronic if you think about those on page
30 this should happen it's like okay I
guess I don't want you to ask given the
films that we've discussed today are all
based in fact whether there's as the
word responsibility hangs over you more
as a writer in doing fact-based films
than it would if you had something that
was completely fictional and you could
create the morality of the characters
the morality of the the world in which
it takes place it may well I mean I'm
sure I do feel a lot of responsibility
but I think I would feel that way if I
ever got a job writing a science fiction
movie - and I and I would take slight
issue with the word fact because I mean
the actually Detroit is quite factual
more so than people realize but it's not
so much fact that I'm concerned with as
the underlying truth of the situation
and I I do feel responsible but but but
not in a bad way I mean not in a
troublesome way I mean I just I want to
do things that I can be proud of so it's
not so much like a obligation other
people as just like being able to look
myself in the mirror
and thanks for being here this is all
been really interesting and wonderful as
a young screenwriter who doesn't want to
write Thor for me there are really few
people whose work is more inspiring and
the more for role models so it's it's
really a privilege to listen to this
tonight I want to ask about the
political aspect of your work I've
written a few screenplays one based on a
racially charged police shooting one
based on a young American man who was
recruited into Isis both true stories
based on people I know and when we've
gotten to the hands of Hollywood types
they say you know good stories but too
political so my question for you is how
do you write such politically charged
and poignant work without it being too
political i when we finish when we were
I'll tell you a little story when her
locker was finished we had quite a hard
time finding a distributor because we
that we raised the money to make the
movie independently and the money all
came out of Europe it's not a I mean the
financier was lived in America but he
was French and all the money came out of
here anyway so then it was quite a job
to find somebody to actually put the
movie out and we sold it to a company
that doesn't exist anymore I won't name
them but because there's people supposed
to work today but anyway they we found a
distributor and for in the very first
meeting an executive whose name I won't
say cuz he's still working today I had
another company anyway he said it look
movies great really intense and
everything but do you think it has to
take place in Iraq I thought well we're
I mean what what do you mean like I mean
it's in every shot you know and he said
the same thing he said you know it's
really political and a bit of a
hot-button issue and the story is
amazing and the tension and the bomb and
the guy being sort of wrapped up in this
sort of addiction and all that is cool
but like could you know if it could be
set somewhere else we'd really have
something commercial so
and you may have it right actually but I
completely sympathize with our response
I don't have a good answer for you but
you but maybe you know help you to know
you're not the only person that gets
asked that stuff so presumably as a
journalist you're used to working
writing on your own and going and doing
the research and you're on your own a
lot and then I just had a question about
the process with now writing with film
I'd imagine at some stage you discuss
with the director what you know the
script and and your both vision on how
that pans out etc but do you have like
personally people that you go to with
drafts of the script that you show that
you get feedback from or do you have
quite an isolated process I mean there
are a few people I'll show drafts to I'm
a bit sensitive about that because I'm
very susceptible to especially when I'm
writing to almost anything that I'm that
I hear and I'll probably tend to over
value or over weight either either
praise or criticism so I'm protective
not because I don't I mean not because I
think that you know people are mean or
unhelpful but just because I just don't
trust myself too much with with that
with that kind of input and then but
globally I mean I since I've made three
movies with Katherine you know we before
I would even write I mean we would talk
a bit about what it is I'm trying to do
so it's not as if I'm working in a
vacuum and and I would talk to I mean in
this case the the idea for the movie the
first person I talked to was the was
Meghan Allison I mean outside of my
company outside of the people that I
work with every day but it was Megan
Ellison and you know that was a
conversation
how the movie might work financially so
it's it's not like created in a vacuum
but I do but I do try to I do try to
limit comments is my great honor to be
here and talk with you and one of my
favorite lines from your script is the
[ __ ] who found this place said
by Jessica Chastain and surely we have
find very strong and powerful male
characters in the war all political
films but Gerald dark thirty is an
exception and the character Jessica
Chastain bill has very strong powerful
and impressive characteristics so I want
ask when you create this kind of female
characters is there any particular
factors you will consider to put in your
script yeah thank you so much
you mean because it was a female yep not
really I mean again she was inspired
there's sort of a real-life analog to
her so the way she spoke and so forth I
mean that was inspired by the way this
person I mean she's quite a foul-mouthed
individual quite Street in her
presentation even though she was well
educated and so forth I think actually
Jessica played her with a bit more
elegance but no I didn't think and I
tried not to think of that because I
think that would lead to a weird sort of
had space and so the only time I thought
about her you know the only time that
enter would was more in the way I
thought about other characters viewing
her than in the way she presented
herself so I did spend a lot of time
thinking about how would have seemed to
other people in the agency in let's say
Islamabad when
a young woman showed up to do this work
which is very you know I mean you can
traditionally be quite macho and so
thinking about that then like little
lines pop into your head there's a
moment in which Kyle Chandler who plays
the CIA station chief sort of gives a
kind of aside to a Jason Clarke's
character as they both first see Maya
walking in to their offices and it's
just sort of like oh I see we qing mian
or something and it's sort of a sly
reference to her looks so stuff like
that I thought about but in terms of her
the way her mind worked I didn't I just
sort of thought of her as an analyst and
quite frankly a bit one of the
challenges of the movies there's so much
information in it all those streets that
are being listed but those are like
actual streets that I had to figure out
where they were and everything and
there's you know figuring out the family
tree of al Qaeda which is represented
again probably more accurately than
people realize in a movie that was quite
you know that was quite a lot of took it
took a lot of mental work so that's what
I thought about it kind of follows on
from questions that have already been
asked but I think one of the things that
really strikes me about your films is is
actually that you don't give a lot of
cues as to how people are supposed to
perceive people the characters in your
films you there is that balance between
an impartial depiction of a sort of
honest and real event or real things
that have taken place and you've spoken
a lot about the word agenda and politics
I was just wondering how how does that
change from the process of writing your
screenplay to working with you were
saying
that you were thinking sort of with the
actors in mind that you're writing for
when you actually come to working with
them especially with things like Detroit
where you're working with young
african-american actors now how do they
sort of perceive the writing that you've
or the lines that you've given them and
do you feel like it does come across as
more of an agenda when you've when it's
interpreted by them or do you think that
I don't know that's about it well in the
case of Detroit I wasn't actually I
didn't really do any rewriting on set I
wasn't actually there was my time I was
sort of splitting my time between that
and another project by the time it was
filming so and that that was much it was
a little unusual for me because I'm zero
dark thirty in The Hurt Locker I was
kind of there every every day and it's
kind of like pretty involved in almost
every frame and and in the case of
Detroit I think I probably had a few
conversations with actors not every one
of them but just but not not not all
that much actually so it was that was a
more typical experience of handing a
script off and then not really having as
much influence on how it turned out but
in terms of the writing so I don't
really know how to answer that question
but in terms of the writing the
orientation of the writing I there was a
when I back when I used to do a lot of
prose writing there was a teacher I had
who talked about the point of view of
the writer to his subject and and one of
the things that he was encouraging was
to kind of look as a writer at the
subjects as if you were at eye level
with them and sort of on the same moral
plane which is which sort of stayed with
me and so that is that that is how I try
to do it and not every writer does that
there's a lot of writers that
if you really look at the work there
they're assuming a slightly elevated
position to their characters as if they
have slightly more knowledge of the way
the world works and their characters do
which is fine I mean it's something
against that but it's it's and that's a
particular approach and so I tried not
to do that and try to just know what my
characters might know and you know I
have no idea what what the actors
thought of that to be honest but that's
where I start it must be interesting
when you then watch it back to see how
your lines have been interpreted by
those people and I imagine it must be
sometimes surprising to see how it comes
across what you wrote one time and then
to see it performed do you ever feel
like wow that's given a new life to what
I sort of interpret or how I well yeah
completely I mean having your work
performed by actors is an amazing
experience it's actually probably the
best part of this job and we did a table
read of The Hurt Locker early on with
some friends and I was quite depressed
afterwards because I thought oh my god
the script is terrible and Catherine
said no no it's just it's these the
actors weren't really you know it's not
that there were anything wrong with them
but then and then when she cast Jeremy
and we did another reading I had the I
thought oh my god I'm a genius and so it
I mean it really does come down to
casting so much and a good actor can can
give almost anything life and so it's a
great great pleasure and a great
privilege to have your work performed as
opposed to just written and I mean it's
it's fun to write in everything but it's
but it's really it's an honor to see
somebody put themselves into it and
inhabited and yeah there are times in
your surprise than you think why'd you
go in that direction but for the most
part it's it's it's it's quite amazing
you mentioned that you are working on
something about the last American
election talked to a number of
filmmakers recently who said just don't
really quite know what to do
because it's also strange when current
events are so strange that it's almost
beyond being able to cope with it is
that something that you felt - no I'm
gonna sort it out forever thank goodness
for that no of course it's strange but I
but I think but I did feel a certain
responsibility I mean the sound a little
corny but I had another project that I
was planning to do and then after the
election I was so struck by the
direction the country was turning that I
felt like a bit obligated to I don't
know to Tanjore the phrase somehow and
so hopefully and I do think there's
quite a lot of confusion out there and
that's one of the things that dramas can
do it I mean there's quite a lot that
could be said about the war for example
there's quite a lot that could be said
about the hunt for bin Laden or police
brutality or the Detroit rebellion but
one of the things that dramas can do I
think effectively is distill and and
centralized in a way hopefully not that
brutalizes you know the truth but in a
way that's enlightening so I think a lot
of artists I'm not the only one but a
lot of artists I think I think it's
actually gonna be a good time for movies
because I think a lot of artists are
responding to the sort of external chaos
and thinking now hold on a second I
should do something here and so we'll
see I think there's gonna be a lot of
good stuff coming in out in the next
couple of years thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]